here bachelor mr. America we'll see how
it goes alright so give us your first
name last name spell out for us yes
where you're from Venezuela
all right and so from Venezuela but
you're competing in what's the name me
summer mr. America mr. right I don't
know bachelor I wish to write something
like that this is funny mr. America it's
mr. America yeah that's right mr.
America that's what I'm competing yeah
that's it one yeah
so even though you're not from America
where I think you got it no I was born
here are you are luckily born here so I
can do the mr. America thing you know I
got the double Passport I'm good I'm
good
so you have a whole back story of that
uh yeah yeah - like that was studying
here so I was born luckily born in
Ithaca New York and then we get back to
Venezuela yes of course with
bachelorettes mr. America you have to
have a long talent competition yeah so
what might happen I don't even know they
put some stuff there I don't have a
specific talent because they didn't read
the soccer ball and that's all I kinda
know how to do but then I just guess I
just go with the we'll see how it goes
all right so and then um do you think
this is a good way for it's a really
sort of capture Desiree's attention
right I don't know my bungo so whatever
you call is gonna be a good way of
captain for me to get your attention
better you know you work on it hopefully
you get a little bit of attention here
then
you have when you can head up to those
little dates you get more attention have
you impressed her already so far I think
so yeah well I was I'm the lone ranger
yeah well I won The Lone Ranger
one day all right all right but um the
point is I mean I guess to sort of
immunity I guess would is from what
Desiree is looking for and do you feel
like you have what inputs that sort of
window to Lana
Thanks so you know she's a really cool
girl she is very smart very funny so I
got a couple of things there that are
working pretty good and there's a bunch
of guys too you know 12th grade guy so
well say I goes out I think we pissed
Talan
I might get some points today and we'll
check if she keeps me around one more
week nervous about the swimsuit
competition at all competition I'm okay
I don't think I'm that nervous there's a
guy here this for him he's gonna win it
you know but it's fine you know there's
nothing against that learn any tricks
yet I mean because you know female
contestants are usually all waiting to
talk to me some america-first you can
tell me some tricks you know might be an
angle or someone like that she'll tell
you pick up Dolson and I'll do it
because the female contestants they say
they usually they have like tape or
something to keep everything in place
especially during a swimsuit competition
so maybe show oh my goodness tapes might
figure out there's some jello some weird
things to put on but I'm not sure how
this America to see how she can help me
out with something